hey guys it is the 23rd of April my name
is Jess little and your chin don't
against bunnies first up today from
software have finally patched Blood
Bones horrendously long loading times
probably just in time for you to have
lost interest in it the games 1 point 0
3 update hopes to minimize your
frustration by bringing down the time it
takes to load the next scene by 5 to 15
seconds the game now also gives you
something to read while you wait similar
to previous Souls games the meaty part
is 2.7 gigabytes and also fixes a number
of bugs related to inoperable lip
immobilized bosses and story progression
issues among others if you're a clever
person who makes much for Skyrim valve
are now letting you sell fed mods in the
Steam Workshop creators will be able to
set the price for mods items and maps
and they're able to change their prices
often release of course they can still
opt to keep their creations free like
before if they choose in accordance with
valves user agreement you are entitled
to a refund if you aren't satisfied with
your purchase and you file for your
money back within 24 hours up until now
Steam Workshop creators could only sell
their items for valve games like tf2 and
started to but valve said in January
that they had plans to open this up to
third-party games there are currently
over 24,000 free mods available for
Skyrim and to date they seem more than
170 million downloads alongside this
news Bethesda have announced the Skyrim
creation kit has been updated with new
features like the removal of file size
limit restrictions and the ability to
upload master files finally Batman
Arkham Knights AC system requirements
have been unveiled just two months
before the games ready to learn
Arkham Knight will require at least six
gigabytes of RAM and forty five
gigabytes of hard drive space while the
recommended benchmark calls for 8
gigabytes of RAM and fifty five
gigabytes of hard drive space rock
steady also released their ultra system
requirement for those of you who want to
get the game looking as beautiful as
possible the only difference between
these and the recommended specs is that
you'll need at least a geforce gtx 980
graphics card as opposed to a geforce
gtx 760 you can find the full minimum
recommended and ultra system
requirements on gamespot let me know
down in the comments if you think
charging for mods is a good idea or not
and why you can head against what we've
got stories on Square Enix's III press
conference and how style was the other
point is going to be different to
battlefield as always to leave me your
thoughts down below and pop back same
time tomorrow where I'll have my top
five stories of the whole gaming week
I'll see them
you